so hello everybody I would like to
welcome you to this conversation I am
speaking with father Stephen Freeman
father Stephen Freeman is in an Orthodox
priest he's also a blogger he's also an
author he's written a book and he speaks
all over the US on different subjects to
different churches and I met father
Stephen a few times I've read his blog
and I followed his podcast also he has
sometimes podcast and I think that a lot
of his ideas are close to the types of
things that I'm interested in getting
all of you to understand about how you
know Christianity is actually talking
about reality and we're talking about
how things lay themselves out how we
connect reality and when we talk about
God it's not this arbitrary thing but it
really is something that we can intimate
in our in our experience
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
until father Stephen maybe you can tell
us a little bit about yourself I know
you're you're a priest but you're also a
an orthodox convert maybe you can tell
us just a quick glimpse of what you're
doing what you're interested in and and
then we can dive right into the subject
yes thank you it's good to be with you
and for myself I am convert my family
and I entered the Orthodox Church in
1998 for about twenty years before that
I served as an Episcopal priest so if
there's one thing that would tie those
two traditions together would be
Anglicanism for a long time had a real
feel for beauty for liturgical things
and and some feel for the tradition I my
sense for orthodoxy maybe this is you
could say this connected to reality
orthodoxy can be kind of messy it's got
a 2,000 year history unbroken but you
know that's real that's different than
getting in arguments about whose church
is better whose ideas are better I kind
of look at this as as a given like this
is the Christianity that was given and
it has you know all kinds of
complexities and stuff and gets tied up
in things but that's my life - in your
life it's I kind of think of it as the
real life and not some ideological
construct so yeah yeah and I think that
I think that that's for most people I
think they they find that very strange
because liturgy is something that at
least the modern mind has to accommodate
themselves to and the kind of let's say
this holistic practice of the church
here and and in the hands of the
architecture and the and the and the
icons and everything it's something that
seemed alien at first to to the modern
viewer but maybe you can tell us a
little bit about how it is that that
this experience of the liturgy and the
the encounter of this holistic beauty
how does it connect to our life and to
who we are as human beings well one of
the ways I think about it really is
under the word tradition meaning just
that which has been handed down to us to
me tradition is not something made up by
people when people say this is just you
know the ideas of men a tradition is
just you know like my father telling me
about how things work do my grandfather
was a mechanic my father was a mechanic
my two brothers are mechanics how did
they learn how to do that somebody had
to teach them they didn't reinvent the
notion of machines in the same way so
many things about our life that are just
like that the liturgy as well in a sense
liturgy is a very traditional human
behavior I like for instance when people
come into an Orthodox Church there are
some stands with icons holy pictures on
them and that sort of we kind of connect
with that we'll traditionally greet them
with a kiss or whatever I built a small
little stand a little short one with
icons on it for the children because
about half of my congregation or
toddlers mm-hmm you can watch a child 18
months to two years old and this is all
the time you see this on a Sunday
morning who come in and literally just
sort of lay on the icon stand hugging it
and giving it a kiss and go in and
nobody nobody told them to do that
nobody gave them a theological
explanation of the simple connection
between a child and this this image of
something they're coming to love it's
just natural they might do the same
thing at home with a favorite stuffed
toy I I also would say the most natural
thing that children do is is play the
theorist Piaget one of your French buds
Piaget his
theory of learning was that children
learned by playing you know they act
stuff out you know you're gonna play
house you're gonna play we played
mechanics when that was good
constantly taking our bicycles apart
kind of going through the ritual and
because play is actually ritualized
behavior right and so I sometimes say to
people that liturgical life in the
church is we're playing heaven we're
doing something the most natural thing
which is adults engaging in a ritualized
behavior in which we're acting out
outwardly something that is inwardly
true I mean we do these things all the
time you come home from work you you
kiss your spouse it's a ritual why do
you do that I mean there's nothing it's
just a ritual we don't do it in you're
in trouble you know I agree I agree I
think that there's something that I've
been thinking about for quite a while is
that is the inevitability of ritual you
know you have so many that we don't
realize we you know you shake hands the
way we we look at people we have all
these manners of so these matter that
we've agreed upon of how to act with
each other and so when people when
people talk to me and they say you know
I don't like churches that are
ritualistic I don't like the ritual I
think okay that's odd you you seem to be
disconnected with a very important
aspect of what it it is to be human and
so I would say that ritual is something
like ordered action you know just in
general like it's it's action that is
it's like hierarchical action that has
an order within it and that we can we
all together acting you need that you
know if you're going to act together you
need there to be some kind of implicit
order in which you're acting together
and so and in the church we we kind of
take that to the next level because
we're also we're also celebrating you
know it's it's a celebration but at the
same time it's not a it's not a
disorderly celebration it's an ordered
celebration it's a you know it's also
everybody looking together in the same
direction everybody singing the same
things and there's this there's also
multiplicity within it people have their
different different parts to play but it
all comes together in kind of this great
symphony I always think that you know
this this idea of ogner that he talked
about the perfect work of art and he
said that opera was you know the perfect
work of art because it it had all that
you know it had narrative but it also
had music and it had visual aspects and
everything and I was thought no longer
is wrong that the liturgy is the perfect
work of art because you're inside the
art you're not you're not a spectator in
the liturgy you're actually
participating in this kind of this just
this this giant dance that's going on
around you well I think the the the
element of song portal vogner could go
on for hours and he's still trying to
get it seeing but they it in I think one
of the things that works for the church
particularly the the tradition of
liturgy is that you know it's funny like
Protestants technically rejected all of
that sort of thing and then they
invented things like Masons and which
they do highly stylized ritual things in
which when you're doing it you just feel
very very hokey and you know and and
it's not it doesn't feel authentic and I
think of I mean liturgy is an extremely
natural behavior and you you kind of
learn how to do it and you walk within
it it should not be highly stylized it
should not be self-conscious but
actually you're doing it because I mean
as a Christian you're not just acting in
a symbolic manner but you're you're
doing what you do because you believe
what's going on is real it's reality
you're dealing with and these things
they reveal things to us about who we
are about how the world is about how you
know how to teach things for instance I
think I tell parents you've got children
coming of the church and typical of
North adducts Church it's highly
decorated it you know there's icons
various things like that and I I say to
them I believe the human soul cannot be
without the experience of beauty but
often times and our extremely
you know marketable world beauty is you
know we build things for utility
practicality and you know here in the
suburban eyes South frankly cities are
just are oftentimes ugly or areas around
them are just ugly and so I think of our
kids it's coming into church and for a
little oasis of time in the space of a
week they're exposed to beauty and
Wonder and things that they they can't
get anywhere else music even music that
they can sing and participate in and so
what do you think you go to be talking
about beauty how do you see because
beauty you know especially for someone
who's a let's say like a strict
materialist or someone who is really
focused on on kind of scientific
thinking the beauty becomes almost a
subjective idea you know it's like what
I like is what's beautiful but I think
what you are talking about or what
you're bringing us to is something which
is more it's more objective that there
is something about beauty which kind of
imposes itself on us or surprises us or
kind of you know or brings us together
and that this this this notion of beauty
or this aspect of beauty is is something
that we almost need that it's a it's
like it's a human need that we have
something that makes us feel human yeah
I mean I think if Beauty were purely
subjective there couldn't be art museums
when people go into art museums they're
going in to see agreed Beauty right and
you know if it was all you know just
subjective who would pay to go see
something beautiful the the it's
something within the modern mind and on
some of it has to do with various
streams we've had in our you know sort
of philosophical cultural things as
we've lost all confidence in ourselves
mm-hmm that you know the notion that it
that beauty is just subjective means
that I don't
we believe it's beautiful or that my
belief that it's beautiful
is very tenuous and ready to be knocked
off its feet because it's merely
subjective and there can't be any
communion with that because you think
it's only inside you and part of the
experience of duty first off it's
outside you well but then it's also
inside you it's an act of communion that
you're reaching out and you you are you
know engaging with it and it's engaging
with you and that's a very fundamental
human experience the the first primary
experience of Duty we have as human
beings is of the human face it is you
know mother and child nursing in in
normal circumstances up into recent
years when we were told as mammals that
we should not use our mammary glands no
every other animal in in earth that's a
mammal but we it's a face-to-face thing
for us there's all kinds of
psychological studies about the impact
of this that a child is is is the mother
and child mirror each other's emotions
and the child has an experience of
communion with that the child smiles the
mother child's it's an affirmation an
experience of that experience of beauty
as they mirror each other when that's
broken four varieties of reasons it is
just simple fact that the impact is you
know it is gonna the negative impact is
going to be real and sometimes if it's
great enough can be an impact we
experience for all of our lives that you
know that the earliest experience of the
world is that I cannot have communion
with it it's very difficult to learn it
and to trust it and so beauty has a
sense of wonder it has a sense as you've
described of order of hierarchy of it
I mean the one thing you can if you go
back to to say cave paintings he thinks
one of the things that's most striking
about some of the cave paintings in
France for instance in Spain um they're
amazingly beautiful simple but I mean
just the you I couldn't do them I don't
have enough artistic talent to draw
animals like that they're not stick
figures they're they've got a flow and
deform they draw you in they have a kind
of mystery about them despite how
primitive they are they they work
they're beautiful and no doubt the
person painting them thought that
experienced that and and taught the next
guy the next woman how to do that as
well cave painter it was a whole
tradition of course of course but I
think there's something that you said
that you brought up this idea of the
human face I think is really important
especially in the Christian the
Christian revelation really then ends up
centering on this experience you know
this kind of immediate experience of the
of the person and and centering beauty
and truth and let's say this communion
in the the human face I think is is is
extremely important it also reveals us
something very important about about
ourselves about how we're connected to -
to the others and so we because in the
Orthodox tradition we do that saying
everything has come now to flow
especially on our notion of beauty is so
centered around the icon we we kind of
are constantly engaged in this
relationship of this encounter with a
person this this idea that you're
looking into a face which is both a
mirror of yourself but it's also
completely another person so you you
stand you know if I if I if I look at
you actually now I'm doing it through a
screen there's a little bit left a
little bit left you know I I have this
mysterious encounter of of Communion and
end and that's I think that's really one
of the most amazing
that I keep telling people that this
idea that Christianity that God is love
that's really the central element of
Christianity and how all of this
connects together which is this
encounter with a person and with persons
that also that reveal how different they
are from you but also reveal how
connected the are to you at the same
time
this kind of push and pull between
between two people well I think you know
that's it's precisely the in an orthodox
understanding when we talk about God
we're not really talking about an
abstraction a set of ideas a set of
doctrines or something like that it's
always grounded I mean that our notion
of salvation that is being changed
becoming whole becoming fully what we
ought to be is most completely expressed
in the phrase of beholding him face to
face that this change Paul says that it
beholding Christ face to face were
changed from from glory to glory that in
that since we're being healed and that
which makes us it you are looking
outside yourself but you're not looking
past the human you you're looking into
the face of of love of of complete self
giving love in the face of the human
being which we as Christians say is none
other than God himself and so that's up
and is something as I say we've been
doing since the day we were born I
always tried to stress when I've got
newcomers to the faith that the the
essential act of what we call salvation
is also but simply becoming truly human
that the wonder is that we were created
in the image and likeness of God and so
being truly and fully human is simply
being conformed to that which we were
always made to be we'd discover our true
self so when I look at say an icon of
Christ
I'm also looking at a reflection of Who
I am yeah you know it's
he's my mirror when I if I were staring
at a mirror of myself you know this like
the it's Chris I tell people these days
as I'm getting older when I look in the
mirror mostly I see my father and I see
my father as an old man it's actually
forcing me to love him more I think that
it's such a key point for me is you know
when you when you start to have a kind
of let's say intellectual awakening in
your 20s often you meet all these kinds
of people who even if they they can
believe in God they have this idea okay
I believe in God but I I believe God is
more like an abstract force is more like
like something that's like you said some
that's abstract something that's an idea
but that is just not our experience of
reality because we are we view the world
through our own consciousness our own
human consciousness we don't know of any
other world besides the one that we can
view through this human consciousness
and we encounter you know the highest
thing we encounter is always other
people you know the more the richest
thing the most the thing that can
transform us the most they can make us
like you said more human are always
other people and so I always find it
strange when people think that the
highest aspect would say the highest
ontological aspect that you know that
the image of the infinite would be
something that's abstracts like no the
image of the infinite has to be
connected to our experience of the world
which is a personal experience which is
a experience that is through
consciousness so the the the idea all
that when you start to see it that way
the notion of the divine mind or that
that God is you know the best the best
image of God is Christ then it makes it
makes so much sense in it you know it
doesn't it doesn't seem so strange at
all anymore
well something I think that's important
is the distinction between the general
and
particular the truth is is you can't
ever ever ever know anything in general
we only encounter anything in a
particular and so for instance in the
father's in teaching about icons they
said you cannot paint an icon of say the
divine nature right what would that look
like then it's like we why can we paint
an icon of Christ because he became a
man not man because you can't just sort
of paint man you have to paint a man a
woman you know a particular thing and
and there's actually been a drive in
certain aspects of modern art to in fact
try when we talk about abstraction to
somehow another capture or express the
generalized and in a way the more we do
that the people begin to have this sort
of cognitive dissonance in which they're
all standing at staring at something
that no one knows what it is and they're
thinking even to themselves is that art
and well it can be things about it I
mean my youngest daughter is an artist
you know I appreciate that you can have
you know I mean of course on the other
hand I mean you know Picasso can draw a
line and it just has genius about it and
you'd have to look at it and figure out
why that is so his lines are better than
my lines but on the other hand you
finally abstraction just fades away into
nothing
it is the strange act of communion is
that we discover in the particular but
something that unites us with that which
is but beyond it I I like a term that
I've used in referring to God as calling
him the transcendent particular I mean
he's he's he's actually the ultimate
particular because there's only one of
him there's there's not - there can't be
general God because there's only hey God
one God and so he's utterly patís so
utterly in transcendently particular you
know
and so he makes himself known to us in
the Godman Jesus Christ and in a way
that's also a revelation in me I am NOT
humanity I'm just Stephen and you know
and this is how we encounter each other
and I'm you know there's the old saying
I love humanity it's people I can't
stand
exactly know you meet that oh you
encounter that all the times like I love
the poor yeah well I hear this I think
people are going to attack some group
they're gonna attack blacks are going to
attack old privileged white men whatever
like that I'm thinking well which one of
them I mean when we reduce each other to
two abstractions that's actually first
off you have to generalize anybody in
order to kill them we won't get very
difficult to kill particular people
because particular people are always not
quite what you imagine I have to
actually sort of stigmatize you and
paint you as something broader that I
can just paste my hate on make you stand
as a fault symbol for all that's wrong
with your you know your ID your race
your nation or whatever that way this is
always a ticket to violence we find love
in the particular we find forgiveness in
the particular we find Union and
communion with the particular the other
after a fashion and I would say this
I've written that that modernity that is
the modern project is inherently violent
it wants to manage control change it
doesn't want to be no it doesn't want to
behold it doesn't want communion it
wants to make things be what we want
them to be and in doing so create the
better world it's a very dangerous
slogan so I think I think that that's
something that I mean I think some
people are starting to see it some
people are trying to to to try to
separate the wheat from the chaff or try
to they want they don't want to see the
relationship because between let's say
the modern project
modern thinking or the Enlightenment
thinking and the environmental crisis or
is kind of the manner in which we treat
reality as you know how did I talk about
the study of the standing reserve that
we treat the world as just this reserve
of physical potential that we can just
take and make whatever we want to make
but I think that it's I think that it's
an essential relationship and it's very
difficult because it's hard to see it's
hard to see a way out of that it's hard
at least socially it's hard to see how
if you've gone so far down that road
that it's very difficult to imagine it
in in political terms the only way that
I can imagine it is in like you said in
particular terms to say I you know I
will myself try then to to inhabit a
different life as much as it's possible
you know it's the first habit of modern
thought is to see something that's wrong
and then think about fixing it and which
is like we leap to the political cuz I'm
gonna make a better world I think no no
that was the problem to start with a
better world you know that that sort of
in the Christian spiritual tradition if
anything it wants to tell us to slow
down to pay attention to who you are to
where you are to pay attention to the
particular and of course when I start
talking like that modern listeners it
get extremely nervous because they're
afraid if they do that somehow another
no one will pay attention to the larger
world excuse me I have a dog that was
his greeting of the mailman there you go
they have a a particular relationship
[Laughter]
the when when you know when we stop and
slow down and we're not gonna control
the rugs the truth is I like to ask
people when they go all political about
stuff I kind of miss a how's that
working for you when was the last time
you thought it actually you know changed
anything it mostly just changes and
makes you
angry yeah that's what happens we feel
self-righteous because we can look at
the world and see how bad it is and say
well shouldn't we change this shouldn't
we change that and we don't we're not
looking at our own sins at our own our
own frailties that our own broken at our
own broken relationships yeah one of the
one of the benefits of older times of
living in a monarchy is you actually
knew who you could blame it is it is the
king and so sort of one of the illusions
of democracy is those who actually have
the power have us all convinced that
we're in charge and I mean it's like in
the Soviet Union everybody voted yes guy
cuz you only had one candidate but they
were called like the Democratic Republic
of so inspired and so so turn eats and
writes and says basically refused to
participate in the lie you know don't do
things you don't actually you know agree
to or whatever it's sort of trying
calming his fellow citizens back to to
the particular and not being allowed to
be abstractions the I as a Christian I
just don't know anything about how we
change the world I don't think that
we're given that as a commandment we
were given Commandments about how to
live how to actually live and I suppose
you know you could do the math and say
if we actually live like that it would
add up to a better world but that's not
my problem that's that's in the hands of
God and when I start thinking like that
I've exchanged being someone who lives
right to someone who wants to make
everybody else live right and there's
the violence again of the modern world
and so instead you slow down you take a
look you start seeing beauty you start
living truth you try to do the good
thing and you know in doing this in the
face of the particularity of made known
to us that for me as a Christian made
known to us in Christ it this is what it
looks like to do that
and we have examples in history where we
see how it actually changes it actually
does change the world we see the example
of the Christian martyrs is a I mean
it's the most glorious example where
here are these people basically just
saying no this is this is you know I'm
not I'm going to stay true to what I
believe said true to who I am and not
but I'm not going to fight the social
system I'm going to accept to die you
know and not protest and then change
that transform the Roman Empire it
converted the Roman Empire it's crazy to
to you know to think that that possible
but we we've seen the Christian story do
that in st. Francis of Assissi is a
great example of that where he just said
it's just me I just I'm the I'm the
smallest of all I am the servant of all
I'm you know I'm the and then he changed
Christianity in until today he
transformed the all the intent
transformed the Catholic Church by by
not wanting to revolutionize anything
but just wanting to follow Christ into
to to to do these humble things you know
everything changed
no in it may not always work out like
that but a couple of years ago here in
the US and maybe still going on
big big debates about guns and things
like that and I you know you get on
social media and there's just you know
no guns lots of guns I hate hate hate
and I I posted and just basically said
my response to it is is I promise I will
not kill you that as a Christian this is
my this is my promise to the world is I
am NOT going to kill you because I
believe in God and because I believe
that he's in charge of history and its
outcome I can tell you that I don't need
to kill you and I won't kill you
someone immediately said but what if you
live in dangerous neighborhood and I
said well then I'll move I mean I it's
it's kind of mean the response to that
isn't well let me get enough guns so
that I mean you can't outgun them you
know psyche don't live like that don't
live like that and I you know people can
argue is that Pratt
I just you know I we all I can say is
you know bless God it's not working out
that these things the end the arguments
are endless and people are never getting
around to just living and you know I
think this is a fundamental part of the
Christian vision is that we should live
I mean I think one of the great present
tragedies in Christianity is the highly
politicized things that are going on
that in which many Christians are
absolutely convinced that there's a
culture war and that their greatest
Christian duty is to be a culture
warrior and and you can get that from
both left and right yeah and and in that
frequently they're all engaging in
generalities I mean the culture war is
us versus them and us and them are both
generalities and there's no there's no
there can be no love in it and there's
no transformation you know if either
side one you still want and wouldn't
want to live in their world yeah and I
think that that's I mean but at the same
time it's true that that's the hardest
thing is the hardest thing is to it's so
much easier to be you know I say that
because I'm on social media I'm on
YouTube I'm doing all this and it's it's
a lot easier to do that to comment on
different posts than to pay attention to
the people who are around you the people
you know to your family to the to your
neighbors to the community that's
directly around you and engage with them
see them as people and and be a you know
be that particular who's who who is
manifesting Christ and is seeing Christ
and others you know to the to the the
most that they can do but it's yeah we
get polled I mean I feel that I feel
getting pulled into political sphere I
try to avoid it people none might you
think I don't know that sometimes I like
I go a little bit in and then I'm like
no I need to get back to the patient
it's a great temptation but you think
about Christ and his interaction
there were you know in some ways Israel
at the time was a highly politicized
thing you had your groups you pharisees
and sadducees and other groups and then
you had the you know those who were
religious and those who were considered
the unrighteous you know prostitutes and
tax collectors and things that way and
he he not only you know they talked
about him meeting and eating with
prostitutes and tax collectors and these
other near the wells but more amazing
that than that I think about it we know
some of their names I mean for instance
there's a short little man in the town
of Jericho named Zacchaeus who is a tax
collector and hated by everybody in the
town the amazing thing is I mean how
obscure is that 2,000 years ago some
dude named Zacchaeus and we know his
name why because Jesus called his name
out and said I'm gonna go home and eat
with you today
he didn't just sort of say you know some
general invitation to all local tax
collectors come and we'll have a meal
because Zacchaeus and it's interesting
Jesus is walking along sees this guy in
a tree and he knows his name and he says
Zacchaeus come down not you and the tree
come down but that kiyose you come down
and we had this consistently these
encounters that are highly personal and
which he sees the person not for their
sin but not for their brokenness not
even for their their larger commitments
like Pharisee or whatever else he just
sees them we know the name of a Pharisee
Simon whose house he ate in and a woman
watched Jesus feet we know the name of
the Pharisee Nicodemus and of others we
know them by name because this was
personal encounters in the book of
Revelation talk about art in the book of
Revelation one of the sweetest things in
it of the vision of heaven is I will
write a new name on you or like I will
reveal to you the you know the truth of
who you really are I will tell you your
name and it's sort of like and when you
hear it
I think the the sense would be of at
last the complete revelation of the
truth of your being would be made known
in the name God speaks to you that is
you know utterly who you are and I mean
a name is is in that sense uniquely
personal you you you walk into the room
you say Steven you have my attention
and so there's this this particular but
the particular isn't to reduce things
it's just it's actually the only way we
ever have communion with anything yeah
you know it has to be yes I think you
see it like I mean one of my favorite
let's say gonna paraphrase but one of my
favorite quotes from from st. Maximus
the Confessor is when he talks about you
know he says you know as the person you
know even a person who is discovering
let's say the spiritual essences of
something and he sees these spiritual
essences that they separate from the
particulars he sees that no there's no
contradiction they're not opposed to
each other they're actually they're
actually made to be together like that's
the whole that's the whole key of the
Incarnation is that we're not called to
this kind of you know this abstract
world but we're called to encounter the
world as a embodied reality and so and I
think I mean it's very it's very
mysterious it's very mysterious when you
think of it in terms of the totality you
know we think we talked about revelation
we think of it in terms of this kind of
final revelation when everything is
great comes together it's it's difficult
to fathom how this particularity is all
going to come together but but we can
you know in our experience like we've
been talking about in weeks in our
experience that's how we experience it
that's how we experience the world I
mean you can say that to degree the
great revolution intellectually if I
could say it that way in Christianity
was I mean already in Plato there is a
discussion of the transcendentals that
is goodness truth and beauty and there's
a recognition that this is important
this is what we should be talking about
what happens in Christianity is that
language gets taken up but there is a
recognition that the transcendentals are
in fact to be encountered in the
particular and that becomes the
revolution in which I mean for instance
the word person as we know it today is a
Christian invention you were just that's
you had a thing you were a helot you
were a slave you were a something and
suddenly but you become a name of every
person of equal value B we couldn't say
that all people who admitted created
equal
without that revolution having occurred
it gave infinite value to the particular
whereas prior to that there was only
infinite value to the infinite and in a
way you can't you can't get it in your
hands and in the Incarnation and and
what that sets in motion in the life of
understanding is a drive towards I mean
when God becomes man the infinite enters
the particular and the particular you
know is revealed to have infinite value
and that's a complete change but nothing
is just dispensable everything has
infinite value and that's you know
that's really the drive of Christian
ethics is understanding that a human
life is a uniquely particular thing
unrepeatable with infinite value and
worth sacrificing loving I mean it
sacrificing for loving doing all all
that and that is only you know that
without that I'm only speaking vague
generalities it's only in the particular
that we encounter goodness truth and
beauty so that's that's really the root
of incarnation for us yeah right and I
think that it's almost as if we haven't
completely we haven't completely
understood the ramifications of that
until today you know we haven't it seems
when you think about it it just creates
such a there's it creates such a
jam in your mind you know to think about
it that way but it also intuitively
there's also something very deeply
intuitive that makes us that makes it
that it has become the core of our
ethical thinking I mean like we talk
about this all the time that even now
the the secular ethics they are based in
this incarnational thinking even almost
without without knowing at this notion
of this the value in the particular and
this and the value of the of the
individual is something which has come
through the incarnation but now you know
in the prayer in the modern project
we've seen also how it has slipped aside
when Christianity is completely not out
of the of the arena then all of a sudden
that has to go to and then this collect
this crazy collectivism just just
appears and just takes over and then
human beings become numbers they become
just you know fodder for whatever
ideology you you're you have a GK
Chesterton said that when the the
tradition gets jettisoned like the
Christian tradition the the consensus of
earlier times its jettisoned he said
it's not that virtue disappears from the
world he said but what you get is the
virtues gone mad
and so you know most of the people out
there are actually basing whatever
they're thinking on some version of the
traditional Christian virtues but
they've lost their connection you know
to to one another and their grounding in
the particular and in these things of
life and they just you know they run
wild yeah and I'm gonna drive us crazy
and so you have competing virtues you
have you know the love of the love of
tribe versus you know other kinds of
things and and it makes us crazy
yeah I think also you know I've great
respect for people who don't believe in
God father thomas hopko of blessed
memory once said that oftentimes it
takes a act of grace for someone to
become an atheist
meaning that you know that they have in
fact rejected a false god that's a good
thing that's a very thing and I always
say to people who say that they don't
believe in God is tell me about their
God you don't believe in I bet I don't
believe in that one - exactly you know
in it's in fact not one I deal with
people who are coming into the orthodox
church and we have a lot of inquires and
people one of the things we spend a lot
of time with is not just me trying to
tell them about God but us working about
with with what is not God yeah rid of a
lot of false images and things and so I
mean there's some terrible terrible
things that had been done in the name of
Christianity particularly in the modern
period for God's sake being a whole
range of the genocide on the American
continent was you know done with you
know under some sort of Christian banner
you know that they the Indians get to be
Canaanites and we get to be the
Israelites and we're gonna drive them
out of our promised land
see that's unfair I mean in a terrible
and tragic thing so someone rejects that
if that's what they take to beat
Christianity well good for them but you
should reject that it's false it's not
true you know I would say as an Orthodox
Christian though and I'm not arguing
denominations or something just talking
about a different way of doing take a
look at what happened in Kent in in
Alaska in which the missionaries from
Russia who arrived there in the 1700s
were taught that they were to behave as
a guest in someone's home and they lived
like that and it's you know there's a
very peaceful story without genocide
without anything that way but a settling
in and an even and ennobling and
acceptance of many things that were
native to the peoples that were
incorporated into their faith in life
and practice just as it had been for
many many centuries across the world and
so they were on the other hand you
can take anything else that you think of
as noble and true and good that human
beings have done in practice and it also
has things about it that are ignoble not
true and not good and including in my
personal life I have all those things
too and so why should I expect the world
to have acted any different than I act
yeah you know instead I have to be about
being different and by the grace and
wonder of God to show that this is
actually possible and so you know and
you know one of the things I say is I
start by promising not to kill you it
was amazing how killing someone can just
mess up a conversation yes alright
father Stephen I I think we've had a
really good conversation and I and I
really appreciate I was really hoping
people could could see you can hear you
could get to know you and I hope that
then all the people that are watching
this that you will look at father
Stevens blog it's called glory to God
for all things and you can find his book
is everywhere present I think is that
the is that the everywhere present
Christianity and a one story universe
yeah and I think I think you're working
on a book now if I yeah I am I'm
actually interestingly it's I
tentatively going to be entitled face to
face in which I look at shame the role
of shame in human life the role of shame
in our encounter with God and both its
abuse and its proper place it's and it's
been I've been working at it for a few
years now it's been hard say like that
the worst thing you could put on the
title would be shame because nobody
would want to buy it exactly so I really
I really I really appreciate you talking
to me
and I will put all the links to - to
your to your website down there so
people can kind of follow through and
you know when you read father Stevens
blog also it's really interesting to go
down to the comments and see these
amazing conversations that are happening
between people who are helping each
other understand and who are kind of
giving each other advice you know so
it's like it's a whole ecology of people
trying to help each other to be better
people so so thank you for doing that
father thank you thank you and ecology
Wow so I hope you enjoyed this
discussion with father Stephen Freeman
please go ahead and check out his blog
and check out his book also just to tell
you guys I've been looking for ways to
thank all my amazing patrons on patreon
and one of the things I've come up with
is I'm starting to give early access to
patrons even if you give just one dollar
or more I'm giving you early access to
many of the videos I'm also doing a
monthly Q&A for all the patrons who can
if you join on the live Q&A you can ask
your questions and if you give a certain
amount you can also ask your questions
in advance and so this is all the way to
try to figure out ways to thank all the
amazing people that have been supporting
me and don't forget that my new website
is up WWE symbolic WorldCom so check
that out and I will talk to you soon